♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WE HAVEN'T DONE THE
FRIEND ZONE AND A WELL BUT WE
FOX.
CHIEF AMONG THEM IS
AINSLEY EARHARDT ON
"FOX & FRIENDS" WHO IS HERE
EVERY MORNING.
SHE HAS A NEW MEMOIR OUT "THE
LIGHT WITHIN ME."
WE WANT TO HEAR WHAT IT IS.
AINSLEY EARHARDT JOINS US.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME ON.
>> Tucker: ARE YOU KIDDING?
ALWAYS PRAY TELL US ABOUT YOUR
BOOK.
>> THEY APPROACHED ME ABOUT
WRITING A BOOK ABOUT MY FAITH.
I HEAR ALL THE TIME YOU ARE NOT
AFRAID TO SHARE YOUR FAITH.
I SAID, THEY WANTED ME TO WRITE
A MEMOIR.
AREN'T YOU 70 YEARS OLD WHEN YOU
WRITE A MEMOIR?
I DON'T HAVE A LIGHT STORY --
LIFE STORY.
I DON'T WANT SOMEONE TO THINK
THAT I AM SO SELF-RIGHTEOUS THAT
I FEEL LIKE I HAVE SO MUCH LIFE
EXPERIENCE.
BUT THEN THEY SAID WE WANT YOU
TO FOCUS ON YOUR FAITH.
THAT IS LIKE GOD SAYING TALK
ABOUT ME, AND YOU CAN'T SAY NO
TO GOD.
SO I WAS REALLY EXCITED ABOUT
THAT POINT.
I HAVE JOURNAL ENTRIES.
I HAVE WRITTEN A JOURNAL FOR
YEARS.
A LOT OF MY JOURNAL ENTRIES ARE
IN HERE, THINGS HAVE GONE
THROUGH, UPS AND DOWNS, HOW I
GOT TO FOX NEWS CHANNEL.
THE THINGS THAT INSPIRED ME, MY
PARENTS.
I TALK ABOUT THE DEATH OF MY
GRANDPARENTS.
I LOST A BABY THROUGH A
MISCARRIAGE.
I'VE HAD SOME DOWNS BUT MANY
MORE UPS.
IT'S JUST ABOUT HOW GOD HAS
BLESSED MY LIFE AND I CAN'T
BELIEVE I AM THIS GIRL FROM
SOUTH CAROLINA WHO IS ON THE
NATIONAL NEWS TALKING TO
TUCKER CARLSON.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
OH, THAT'S BIG.
WHEN YOU WRITE A BOOK, YOU
LEARN, THE PROCESS OF WRITING
TEACHES YOU.
WHAT DID YOU LEARN?
STICK I LEARNED YOU CAN DO
ANYTHING YOU WANT TO DO.
I REMEMBER WHEN MY FRIEND SAID
LET'S RUN A HALF MARATHON.
I SAID ARE YOU KIDDING?
I HATE -- CAN'T EVEN RUN AROUND
THE BLOCK WITHOUT TASTING BLOOD.
SHE SAID NO, WE CAN DO IT.
LET'S DO MORE OF A WALK WITH A
LITTLE BIT OF SHUFFLE.
I WAS LIKE, I CAN DO THAT.
SO I RAN A HALF MARATHON.
WRITE A BOOK, WRITE A CHILDREN'S
BOOK.
NO, I CAN'T DO THAT.
I HAVE TWO CHILDREN'S BOOKS AND
I HAVE THIS BOOK.
I'M NOT SAYING THAT BECAUSE I M
ANYTHING SPECIAL.
MY POINT IS YOU CAN DO ANYTHING
YOU WOULD SET YOUR MIND TO AND
YOU HAVE TO BE SURROUNDED WITH
GOOD PEOPLE.
AS YOU KNOW.
YOUR STAFF IS AMAZING.
EVERYONE WHO WORKS AT FOX BEHIND
THE SCENES, THEY SHOULD GET THE
CHLORINE, NOT US.
BECAUSE THEY DO ALL THE HARD
WORK.
>> Tucker: MY MOM SAID SHE GOT
THIS BOOK DELIVERED BY AMAZON
TODAY.